Washington D.C very very strange City
District maybe it should be a state what
if I told you know how everybody brags
about the fact that DC people make the
most money number one in income in
America and they brag about it yet
they're also number one in homelessness
they're number one in crime by the way
not just any crime pick any crime
they're number one what do you mean by
that larceny number one murder number
one violent crime number one robberies
number one property crime number one I
got a bunch of other data I'm gonna
share with you on why this is taking
place and what the three solutions we
have that DC can actually fix this let's
get right into it but if you get value
from this video give it a thumbs up and
subscribe to the channel let's get right
into it so again DC weird right when you
look at all these stats how is that even
possible they may call this money yet
crime larceny homelessness all of it is
there and by the way here's a weird
thing we even looked at the data to see
when it comes down to 200 000 plus
earners what's the structure of income
earners in DC this is what it looks like
when you look at this people making less
than 10 grand then it goes to 10 to 15
15 to 20 and then you got 75 to 100 look
at the High is one no matter how you
look at it in DC compared to United
States the greatest U.S the Orange is DC
look where DC ranks on people making
over two hundred thousand dollars
compared to the rest of United States
wild how why now let's look at poverty
rate let's look at high school
graduation rate let's look at some other
data to see how they rank here here's
the numbers for them what do they rank
percentage of people who fell below the
poverty line twenty seven thousand four
seventy nine in a family of four in 2021
you know where DC ranked 46th now here's
the next one percentage of public high
school students who graduated on a
timeline of 2018-2019 school year you
know where they rank 51st you know what
that is last place there's nobody else
there ahead of they can't say well at
least we're doing better than this their
last by the way homelessness look at
this chart in 2022 per ten thousand look
at DC
65.54 you know who's happy about this
only one guy's name is Governor Newsom
you know why because he's second place
at 43.95 at least he gets to say we're
not the worst we're not the worst have
you seen what DC is like
66 out of 10 000 2022 BC how and why
let's get into it so why is it such a
disaster number one bad policies have
consequences right let's look at the
policy of DC VC operates differently
than the 50 states due to its unique
status as a federal district its
governmental powers are controlled by
the U.S Congress stated in the
Constitution which means all laws passed
by D.C local government must undergo a
30-day review period by Congress before
they can take effect during this time
period Congress can block the
legislation this was exemplified in
early 2023 the Senate blocked a Criminal
Justice Reform Bill passed by D.C local
lawmakers lawmakers are very limited
with implementing policy what does this
mean you know how they say during covet
we really learned the power of local
government and local policies there is
no local in DC because everything still
has to go through the federal because
they're in BC number two reason why DC
is a disaster is because of poverty
Washington BC is one of the most
segregated cities in America has a black
population of nearly 45 percent that's
nearly half 17 percent of DC residents
live in poverty 30 percent of black
people according to Census Bureau data
the federal government played a major
role in perpetuating segregation in DC
for example the homeowners loan
corporation holc was a federal agency
that was created in 1933 to help
homeowners refinanced their mortgages
during the Great Depression but the holc
also used a racial rating system to
designate certain neighborhoods as
hazardous for Lending in those
neighborhoods were disproportionately
black so that's already ugly stuff that
we're talking about and what they did in
DC but you can't talk about poverty in
DC without mentioning redlining and
blockbusting that was used heavily in
the 30s and 60s and here's what it is
redlining was a practice by which banks
and other lending institutions Drew
lines around neighborhoods that they
considered to be high risk for Lending
these neighborhoods were awfully
predominantly African-American or other
minority neighborhoods as a result
people lived in these neighborhoods were
denied loans which made it difficult for
them to buy homes or start businesses
now what's Blockbuster Blockbuster was a
practice by which real estate agents
introduced a single African-American
family into a white neighborhood then
the agent would use Scare Tactics to
convince neighboring white homeowners to
sell their homes at a loss this would
then create a panic in the neighborhood
and other white homeowners would sell
their homes this would lower the
property values allowing the real estate
agents to buy the property at a lower
price then sell them to African
Americans at a profit these practices
were eventually outlawed but they
heavily contributed to the concentration
of poverty in black neighborhoods and
they made it difficult for black people
to get good jobs and access to Capital
so so far we've looked at policy and
we've looked at poverty let's look at
number three which is crime
unfortunately for people living in
poverty DC implemented very strict crime
laws shortly after Decades of
discriminatory practices that segregated
them into low-income neighborhoods one
of them was the Firearms control
regulation Act of 1975 which prohibited
residents from owning handguns and crime
stats Spike across the board the woman
they came up with this the other one is
the anti-drug Abuse Act of 1986 created
the hundred to one crack cocaine
disparity which means that a person
caught with crack cocaine would receive
a sentence that was hundred times longer
than a person that was caught with the
same amount of powder cocaine did you
hear what I just said so same amount of
crack same amount of cocaine if I got
caught with crack a hundred times more
than I got for just cocaine that's
pretty wild but the anti-drug Abuse Act
of 1986 led to increased arrest and jail
time in DC the law increased the
penalties for drug offenses particularly
for crack looking offenses which led to
an increase in the number of people
arrested for drug possessions and
distribution and according to a study by
the U.S Conference of Mayors the number
of drug arrests in DC increased by 40
percent in the year following of the
passage of adaa the study also found
that the number of African-Americans
arrested for drug offenses increased by
60 percent during this time period and
again because this is a federal district
any crime you committed you're going to
be held accountable under federal and
state law this is the only place we have
it like that America which causes more
severe penalties federal crimes
typically carry more severe penalties
than State crimes for example the
maximum sentence for drug trafficking is
life in prison under federal law but
it's only 20 years under state law in
many states number two different rules
of evidence federal courts use different
rules of evidence than state courts this
can make it more difficult for
defendants to defend themselves against
federal judges and third different
procedures Federal Criminal trials are
typically more complex and
time-consuming than state criminal
trials this can make it more difficult
for defendants to navigate through legal
process hence this leads to harsher
sentencing in BC now if you're like me
you're wondering okay who comes up with
these policies who's running the city is
these Democratic policies Republican
policies DC the first time they ever had
a mayor in DC was 1975. did you know
since 1975 till today they've never ever
had a Republican mayor it's always been
a Democratic mayor so these are policies
led by democrats so when you hear this
and you say Pat two hundred thousand
dollars that's crazy highest paid income
what kind of jobs are these is it
technology is it Finance is it I bet
it's a lot of money managers nope do you
know the second biggest industry in DC
is public administration 17 of jobs in
the CR public administration they're
only second to professional scientific
and Technical Services matter of fact if
you look at the breakdown of income on
this chart that I'm showing you red
represents female blue represents mail
you will see the highest paid income
earners whether it's female or male is
public administration the second highest
is manufacturing then you go into
construction a bunch of other Industries
but public administration for males and
females so what is a public
administrator mean here's a 10 different
jobs they can look at as a public
administrator one is a public
administrator second is policy analyst
three city manager Dennis budget analyst
urban planner non-profit manager human
resource specialist Public Relations
Specialist government Affairs director
Public Health administrator these are
the guys that make the most money in DC
pretty weird right when you think about
the highest paid people in DC are public
administrators really government
employees yep it's the structure to have
in DC so let me get this straight the
people who run America White House these
see all of these guys that work there
can't get their own city right what does
it say about them coming up with
policies so number one the largest
wealth Gap in the world is in DC number
two the highest crime in America is in
DC the highest rate of homelessness is
in DC the bottom five unemployment in
U.S in DC bottom five in high school
graduation rates in DC what does this
say about the people that are coming up
with the policies and DC's it's broken
it ain't working here's our solution
number one solution we look at is crime
and here's what it is in 1982 the City
of Kennesaw Georgia passed a law
mandating that every head of household
residing in the city limits is required
to maintain a firearm what was the
result the result was an immediate 89
drop in residential burglaries and
Kennesaw and a 10 drop Statewide
obviously there's no way to enforce this
policy but the concept of it was highly
effective crime deterrent so remember
the year 1975 is the first time they
started having mayors that year the
first time they ever had a Democratic
mayor here's what here's what passed in
1975. the gun control act prohibits the
position of of handguns in DC except for
law enforcement and those special
permits robberies spiked for obvious
reasons I'm gonna go break into this
house they definitely don't have a gun
let's go in there if I'm stronger than
you I'm gonna get to take stuff out of
your house and I'm gonna be good with it
they realized that was a bad idea so
guess what they did in 2008 the Supreme
Court rules overturns the district's ban
on handguns in home you know what
happened boom immediate Decline and
according to a 2017 study by Pew
Research Center 24 of Washington DC
homeowners own a gun this is
significantly lower than the national
average of 44 I wonder why people arrive
in so many homes there so number one is
crime number two again policy and this
is a suggestion we have DC local policy
should not be dominated by Congress and
federal government the people making
policy decisions are far removed from
the day-to-day issues and can't possibly
know the situation as well as the local
lawmakers so how about if the entire
city they say what if we go out and get
60 70 the city to vote to make this
thing a state where we start making the
laws not Congress and fed Federal and we
have a little bit of control over
allowing these guys to make the decision
because the last thing they're thinking
about is what the city is really like so
somebody said wait a minute you don't
trust the Congress to run it well let me
show you the approval rating with
Congress just the last 18 months here's
what it looks like the highest it's been
the last 18 months is 23 and the lowest
it's been is 16 that's approval rating
if Congress has that kind of an approval
rating do you want them to make the
decisions for your City all the time
probably not BC has got to become a
state to be a little bit more Freer than
these guys making decisions for them
that's something for them to be thinking
about and last but not least is poverty
you've got to figure out a way to solve
this but the issue is a lot deeper than
most people think the number one cause
of crime is poverty at least to
desperation and often leads people to
resort to Crime so how do you reduce
this in a non-socialistic way this
applies to every city this he just
happens to be an extreme example but
housing food energy those three things
that are essential to survive if those
three things can become cheap enough for
everyone to afford the vast majority of
Street crime would be eradicated common
sense right if I make money why do I
have to go rob why do I have to commit
crimes if I make if I'm covering my
bills marriages find my kids are good
I'm fed I come home I have a place to
live I have a place to sleep everybody's
happy I don't need to go do anything
stupid right so how do we change this
climate the place like this couple ideas
number one do what Puerto Rico did
Puerto Rico came up with a plan saying
till December 31st of 2035. if you come
to Puerto Rico yourself a lot of people
do Logan Paul lives there Peter Schiff
lives there a lot of people move to
Puerto Rico you pay four percent in
federal income tax and zero individual
what does this mean if you make a
hundred grand you only pay four thousand
dollars in taxes you keep ninety six
thousand dollars I don't know about this
in Puerto Rico it's a law they passed it
right what if DC did that so people are
not only willing to move there but
they're able to save the money so if I'm
making 50 Grand a year and I'm having to
pay that 20 in taxes 10 grand now I'm
keeping that and I'm only paying four
percent four percent of five fifty
thousand dollars what two thousand
dollars that's great that's an eight
thousand dollar raise immediately if
they can do that right so number one use
a Puerto Rico model to allow people to
keep more of the money to themselves and
that helps people also want to move to
DC the right kind of people are going to
say I'm making 200 Grand a year I'm
making a half a million a year I'll move
to DC I don't have problem moving there
I'll move my business I'm doing five
million I move my business to DC number
two just like other great cities do when
I moved to Texas I first flew out I had
a meeting with the mayor of Frisco mayor
maso then I met with the Governor Perry
then they took me to a Rangers game and
then I said guys we're moving a company
to Texas we moved the company to Texas
we now have a hundred employees in Texas
I don't know how many offices we have in
Texas at this point 20 office in Texas
you think Texas won by moving us over
there of course what if there's
incentives or business owners who want
to move themselves to DC that brings
jobs that helps the economy and crime
goes up those are things that DC could
do if it was a state but there's no way
they can do if all those decisions have
to be approved by Congress it's just not
going to happen what I'm proposing to
you here cannot happen if it doesn't
become its own state if you got value
from this video give it a thumbs up and
subscribe to the channel but there's
another video I want you to watch the
whole premise of this video is the fact
that bad policies can ruin a great City
a great state a great country we did a
video on how Hollywood is getting ruined
based on their policies right now and
they forgot what they were founded on if
you've never seen this video click here
to watch it take care everybody bye-bye
foreign